[Music]
I
he took he goes to Pullman right what
why would that work waiting were you
picturing you're picturing well I'm
pulling his elbow and that's taking its
balance okay that little work is you're
stronger if I can override your force
output with my own force output that
that's not going to work okay and then I
just go on to whatever if I can disarm
it
so this is not what we're doing I'm not
pushing I'm not reading on that I
created a certain geometry in his body
which with my strike was my intention
with my timing with my movement to just
get that word
it doesn't matter whether you do it home
oh I fit down you're not putting on the
hand you're just setting up a particular
geometry everything is doing it to come
back so if I don't have this fight it's
not going to do it if I haven't striking
at a weird angle
it won't do it I have to set it all up
little box it doesn't matter you're
going to be touched up you're just
checking the arm I'm not on it in line
not going like this and check the arm
check the minor oh you're doing okay as
a matter Q geologists side 40 lawanda
but there's also a very negative side
and that is that the environment is
controlled and so you don't take up on
everything it's not meant to deliver
everything that is anything like this is
totally incorrect first strikes count so
my connection is down here not here he
goes and then okay idea so deep he's out
there my connection is already there and
I'm already looking right
pull angle translations first line or I
will really booming with attending
I'm not going like this this is the
wrong mindset you're going to have too
big a bridge between Keyon was up and
then application here is Anna your
connection is out there
you're already timing it boom
once you do they get things you can
start doing these things and if the
candy gets better
this connection gets better okay good
like it's good farming you got the force
shooting out of you do you understand
like I might I might do that because
that's my contact point and I'm doing a
Nabi Lanza okay I do that but you will
talk do it will be 10 attendees if you
see you don't push the target you're not
pushing the target right your honor
boom your your movement is going right
you have your content going you're
driving for elbow and you have your
momentum pop you guys understand that
right right now you're taking your
momentum times away so if you're going
to do the palm me alone it's a palm heel
strike you think if you're going to do
the hand sword it's not like this right
it's your strike hang up in what you do
and you're going to need a hand up you
think
I'm not going to keep that angle on the
set this is my new contact form so in
here right everything stayed the same
just use it to keep the connection fun
yes so don't wait out no I can't hit it
don't keep trying to hit it you not have
the destruction to you use it oh and
then I was taking his balance like that
same way that I thought I wasn't going
like this and taking this balance like
whoa I find your center right and I
create the relationships here and it's a
projection you understand okay you have
to find the center rule so let's look at
this a little bit you you're tending to
be here if that all lines for the target
we have grown now
you've dropped your hands to spin with
that in Iceland it's a movie a terrific
so your first thing is keep your first
intention oh you understand and that
helps create the connection the
relationship and then gold
that's what are you know cool ooh okay
let's say I mess up and I miss it
happens you're going to find absorption
go in there and is negative so I've
missed who she gets the block and you'll
see good pull
I will feel that okay so I'm not going
to try and project online so what I feel
it I just ride it around school Oh feel
it we had to create another projection
point at his elbow boom oh so you're
taking cook you uh nugget that's all
you're just finding cooking on it
wool project remember you're not doing
this kind of leverage there you're not
doing this leverage because you're
different when you're doing this
leverage there right it was body
organization same thing here
home you're not doing this
be cute again hey I'm just turning these
arms and now expecting him to whatever
this movement is still projecting so if
you watch his Center and I turn is armed
and relatively stayed in that same plate
it just turned I'm going to make his
center change its place
boom huh yeah that's the projection so
cool
you
how do techniques and I feel human one
real to them okay but you don't want to
like this not get it again they got to
application of energy white okay so but
here I create a particular relationship
that women and prioritize angle
deviation by and particular relationship
that's my head okay after that right I'm
trying to end it I was trying to end it
people he blocked it so I missed or that
I'm here again so I keep going and he
lets go here and I don't have CI you can
base now because I'm not I don't have to
leave hand right so I just right from
there boom then it would so I don't want
to see you start doing the technique
like this everything is tight
Oh
you